[Musique]
on va te tuer et accueillir celui qui
est avec nous tous les vendredis vous
avez beaucoup plus mais sa chronique la
semaine dernière bien c'est encore mieux
cette semaine il encore plus bosser il a
des vrais chronique
regardez c'est parti c'est stan qui est
avec notre super bien majuro tatane bien
longtemps sur la mais alors ça va mon
statham ouais super alors que tu nous a
ramené aujourd'hui je me suis plongé
dans les archives de tpm p&g du dos
surtout les chroniqueurs à charger des
casseroles qui date de 2009
et j'ai du jour me sens cheveux je vous
jure mais d'abord parlons de l'événement
qui fait flipper vincent bolloré et tout
le groupe canal+ le prime à capuche sur
celui de ce soir alors on s'en souvient
quand cyril avait annoncé que c'était
capus et pas mathieu qui a animé un
prime mathieu était au bout du rouleau
et ses fans encore plus que lui regardez
la réaction du plus grand fan de mathieu
quand il a appris que capus allait avoir
son propre prime tu as plus 6 autres
cadeaux de noël
[Applaudissements]
et elle n'était pas bien je les préviens
aux dates autre chose j'avais plein
d'autres choses
les amis vous le savez peut-être mais
dans quelques jours nous fêterons les
huit en l'évitant de tp npd mais laurent
romejko sida sont des militants de rire
huit ans d'amour huit ans de tulle a vu
mon cul bref huit ans de talent et
surtout huit ans que avril enora jean
luc et jean me font partie de notre
quotidien et ça c'est trop cool
d'ailleurs cyril si votre génie n'a pas
changé votre look oui et c'est tant
mieux si je vous assure
ensuite c'est pas c'était une tête de
bouffon que j'ai pas traité de troyes il
vous a débuté tout à l'heure on va se
manger tout de suite bienvenue dans ce
premier numéro
d'anciens look pour une ancienne vie à
regarder
c'était ce qui nous attend ce soir dans
touche pas à mon poste à ma vie aie aie
aie aie aie aie ça va pas du tout tons
crèmes teintées bas c'est trop beau
ranger c'est trop important plus mauvais
souvenir arrivé non le problème de la
pro grâce c'est juste qu'il faut
utiliser des produits adaptés pour la
peau grasse des crème matifiante qu'on
met dans le maquillage qu'on va mettre
donc justement sur la zone t le problème
de la coiffure c'est qu'on ne peut pas
avoir de volume avec son type de cheveux
on en voit le jour mais on était serrés
on est petit dégueulasse alors on est
dégueulasse aussi toujours je pense
qu'on y vont c'est mieux dans mes bas je
suis sûr que quand on va se revoir dans
cinq ans là aujourd'hui on va dire qu'on
est des eaux et je vous dit en fait on
est toujours le dégueulasse de cacao
d'accord ok j'arrête de païou t on
continuer mathieu encore un allez on
continue à voyager dans le temps
dépêchez-vous parce que je dois au
concert de kent choqué alors que s'est
il passé il ya un an dans tpm tu es bien
à l'époque on parlait médias non pas
avec des chiffres ou des images au que
non on le faisait avec des perruques et
en se jetant des poulpes sur la tête ça
peut paraître bizarre pour les autres
mais ici c'est tout à fait normal et
c'est ce qui fait la richesse de tpm p
regardez
il ya un an bizarrement c'était déjà la
journée de la femme et pour l'occasion
cyril avait invité une très jolie
créature
bonsoir beaux gosses parce que généreuse
m
mais ce n'est pas tout il ya un an ce
n'était pas des pmp au nom c'était le
club dorothée avec dorothée en personne
mais je ne peux pas le regard jean
michel mr et l'année dernière ce n'était
pas jean mi qui tenait des propos
salaces non c'était elle comptera temps
mais au regard des histoires degré aprem
dp2 fou n'est pas parce que si on ne
[Musique]
valorise pas mal un bébé merci à lui on
enchaîne avec le chiffre de la semaine
ses 143 alors qu est ce que c est bien
c'est le nombre de petites jeunes ce que
yahia agathe et vous le dire kim envoie
un sms et elle m'attend au concert de
kenji jusque là simplement d'acheter vos
pas c'est vrai avec la fonctionne mais
cyril vous allez y allez jamais n'avait
que j'irai au concert de kanye
mais ce qu'ils savaient que vous prenez
un risque fou parce qu'il a vraiment dit
qu'il ne viendrait jamais donc les
viendrait nous venons viendra de parole
la gamme et les verts à savoir si vous
êtes là ou pas qui apprend le petit
blond 1 pour me remplacer la le nouveau
le devenir et bien sûr merci
[Rires]
140 fois il nous a fait et nous a refait
le chat tu rêvais d'aller voir si des
gunners où je peux y aller il ya quel
âge 30 ans non c'est faire injure au
moins at-il vraiment romejko temps parce
que je crois que tu avais 16 ans mon
frère grave dénoncée dès 23h de brent
vaut pourquoi alors 143 c'est le nombre
de fourques kevin thomas a fait sur le
plateau mère devenue telle ou refaire
décoller c'est vrai on est tous d'accord
non non non en tant que chien galeux non
mais d'un autre côté la pauvre et ville
était complètement largués dans la
jungle de tpm paix une jungle rempli
d'infos médias et des analyses
pertinentes comme nous le prouvent
normalisé envoyer des sms pendant la
chronique de cette annonce avoir acquis
jaurès et si vous les dents mais
faites-le d'or parce que ça le ça le
gêne locaux parfois n'ont pas dit non ça
me gêne pas merci à m
[Rires]
merci alors donc du coup résultat france
3 a décidé d'adapter tmp en
documentaires animaliers
regardez nous y sommes boisset les beaux
nouveau en liberté est devant nous le
spectacle les ponts de singe de prochain
dans la journée des bonobos se reposer
dorn dans des nuits qu'ils construisent
pour ne pas être dérangé par les
prédateurs les bonobos sont avec les
chimpanzés les singes les plus proches
de l'homme
nous partageons 98 8 7 % de nos gènes
c'est un rival dans son milieu naturel
ces travaux allaient mourir idiot non
c'est fini tu veux je te dise
franchement c'était top est vraiment la
mer va passer sur scène avec le dire car
sinon c'est évidemment bravo bravo mon
chéri avec les sectionnelles vraiment
j'adore j'adore j'adore ce mec